The success or failure of the models that you create
is in a very large part determined by essentially what
are you paying attention to about your data. So, this
is the problem called feature selection. And I think that not
enough time is spent in doing this. It's very, very
important so it's, in a lot of data science shops,
it's very easy to just sort of take, records that
come in, and then put them into a logistic regression, and
you get some output, and then like, you can
call it a day. and, you know, maybe often
times that could be enough to take you, like,
you know, 50% of the way there. But really
the difference between, like, a mediocre and a top-notch
shop, is like you have sat and thought about
what are the things to pay attention to? Like
should I synthesize these features into a new feature?
Is there something new about this phenomenon that I
should be capturing but haven't yet, haven't yet captured? So
there's a lot of sort of there's a lot of
process that goes into, just the feature selection process which
is, is hugely important. More advice, which just occurred to
me, is there's an additional, there's a world of tools
out there that are not merely limited. so, so everything
you would learn in the machine learning class is fantastic.
It forms a great foundation. Beyond there, there's
a wealth of mathematical tools, and the more of
them that you know, the more that it
will help you. So things, for example, like differential
equations, or stochastic processes such as Markov chains.
Knowledge of these things allow you to break down
a problem that you know nothing about. You
can sort of break it down a little bit,
a little bit further into pieces that give you
just that extra bit of predictive ability or or insight
into a problem. And the more tools that you
have at your disposal the more it will help you.